en milieu urbain l’usage veut qu'on
plante les arbres de manière isolée à
une certaine distance les uns des autres
mais une nouvelle approche fait son
chemin au même titre qu'on appelle à la
densification des milieux de vie en
ville ont densifie également la
plantation des arbres bienvenue dans
l'univers des microphorés
[Musique]
on a des outils on a des pelles pour
ceux qui en ont pas petit à troupements
le long du boulevard Rosemont à Montréal
une vingtaine de bénévoles s'apprête à
planter une forêt et pas n'importe
laquelle
les microforêt vous voyez que c'est
vraiment différent de ce qu'on est
habitué de faire le principe c'est qu'on
plante des très jeunes plats tout petits
une grande densité
ici sur 300 mètres carrés l'équivalent
d'un terrain et demi de tennis 900
petits arbres prendront racines
[Musique]
si on va planter trois arbres au mètre
carré aujourd'hui à peu près ce qui est
vraiment différent de nos arbres en
ville où ils sont distancés de 7 mètres
dépendamment de l'espèce et cette forêt
ne sera pas une monoculture loin de là
on y retrouvera 40 espèces différentes
pour la plupart indigène des mélèzes des
chênes des carriers
ils sont plantés de manière très dense
pour un peu les inciter à faire à se
faire compétition puis eux ils vont
chercher la lumière c'est pour leur
survie donc ils vont la théorie ceux qui
vont pousser vraiment plus rapidement du
fait qu'on la compétition entre eux le
concept des microphorets a été développé
par un botaniste japonais Akira miaou
Aki il constate que les forêts nipponnes
avaient été reboisées au fil des siècles
avec des essences non-indigènes plus
productives mais potentiellement moins
résiliente Mia WAKI part alors à la
recherche d'arbres qui avait peu à peu
disparu du paysage sylvicole dans les
années 1960 il recueille des graines
d'arbres près des temples et des
cimetières des lieux qui n'ont jamais
fait l'objet de coupe il se sert des
petites pousses pour reboiser en imitant
le plus possible ce que la nature ferait
au Japon et dans divers pays tropicaux
plus de 1300 sites ont été restaurés
selon sa technique
c'est très bon
on laisse les gens planter les arbres de
manière aléatoire il n'y a pas de
canevas préétabli comme si les graines
avaient été déposées par le vent en
amont l'ingénieur forestière Audrey
boulanger Messier a choisi à la fois des
arbres et des arbustes pour imiter la
biodiversité d'une forêt naturelle à
long terme ils vont pas atteindre la
même grandeur le fait que peut-être
qu'il va avoir déjà un espèce de
sous-étage qui va s'établir sous les
grands arbres reste à voir si ça va bien
fonctionner peut-être que le sous-état
je vais être tellement imprimé qui va
finir par mourir avant que on atteigne
la maturité mais ça va être avoir en
tout à Montréal quatre arrondissements
ont aménagé des microphores cette année
il concept attire également le secteur
privé
[Musique]
nous sommes au bord de l'autoroute 15 à
Boisbriand ce terrain gazonné n'est pas
exactement un haut lieu de biodiversité
mais ils s'apprête à changer de vocation
[Musique]
couper du vent rafraîchir l'espace ici
puis donner une meilleure vue aux gens
qui travaillent dans ces bureaux là
parce que ils voient une autoroute
présentement beaucoup plus agréable de
voir une forêt inspirée par un
documentaire sur l'environnement il
y a Christiane Doyon voulait que son
entreprise de nettoyage face à part
[Musique]
on plante les arbres sur le terrain 300
arbres 17 espèces différentes donc
tout le monde met la main à la pâte
ce sont les employés qui plantent les
arbres et contrairement à la forêt de
l'arrondissement de Rosemont on ne
laisse pas faire le hasard
le terrain a été quadrillé sans parcelle
d'un mètre carré recevront chacune un
grand arbre un arbuste et un arbrisseau
selon différentes combinaisons d'espèces
pour la prochaine
avant d'être mise en terre on mesure le
diamètre et la hauteur de chacun des
végétaux 25 on va revenir prendre des
mesures du diamètre de la hauteur voir
comment les arbres ont poussé et à
partir de cette différence de croissance
on va pouvoir estimer la quantité de
carbone à la quantité de biomasse qui a
été produite et éventuellement la
quantité de carbone qui a été séquestrée
par les arbres chercheurs en écologie
forestière à l'Université du Québec à
Chicoutimi Charles Marty et bénévoles au
sein de l'OSBL qui supervise ici la
plantation il veut savoir comment se
comporte les différentes combinaisons
d'arbres la plupart des études Miyawaki
donc ce système de mini-forêt à forte
densité ont été faites en Asie beaucoup
au Japon il y en a énormément au Japon
en Inde en Asie du Sud-Est mais on
manque on manque un petit peu de recul
il faut savoir comment ça pousse sous
nos climats avec nos sols etc et quelles
espèces sont les mieux adaptées à de
telles densités
[Musique]
une partie de la réponse se trouve ici
on est dans un champ d'agriculture qui
sert à l'enseignement et à la recherche
pour l'université méguil mais on a cette
petite page de forêt là qui fait à peu
près pour les 6 hectares c'est en 2009
que cette forêt très dense prend racine
à Sainte-Anne de Bellevue
le chercheur Alain Paquette de Lucam
nous l'a fait visiter printemps
il y avait beaucoup de monde on avait
besoin de beaucoup de main d'oeuvre donc
ça fait 12 824 arbres à planter plus
ceux qui est important pour conserver un
milieu d'intérieur 13 ans après la mise
en terre c'est désormais une vraie forêt
quand on pénètre à l'intérieur le
contraste avec le champ et frappant
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup moins de lumière qu'on
était à l'extérieur la température est
différente il fait froid bah pas froid
mais il fait beaucoup plus frais et puis
ben on voit que il y a plus de plantes
au sol comparé au champ où on était
tantôt très peu en fait c'est même des
petits semis d'arbres ou d'espèces très
tolérantes à l'ombre qui s'installe
tranquillement et puis ben on voit
beaucoup de branchements et on voit
beaucoup d'arbres morts plus de la
moitié n'ont pas survécu la compétition
pour les ressources comme la lumière ou
l'eau fait que la microforêt s'éclaircit
d'elle-même c'est à partir de la sixième
année que les chercheurs observent que
certains arbres se mettent à mourir ce
qui n’inquiète pas du tout à l'impact au
contraire en plus d'être la dynamique
naturelle d'une forêt c'est fondamental
la santé d'une forêt santé de façon
générale parce qu'on a plein
d'organismes qui sont soit favorisés
soit carrément dépendants des arbres
morts et du bois mort selon qui est au
sol selon qui tient encore debout
on a des champignons qui vont dégrader
le bois qui vont retourner ces
ressources là pour qu'elle soit à
nouveau disponible pour la croissance de
d'autres espèces on a des oiseaux qui
sont bien connus pour nicher dans les
arbres ou se nourrir dans les arbres
morts donc oui il y a toute une
dynamique une forêt c'est loin d'être
que des armes
[Musique]
et parmi ceux qui ont survécu une
hiérarchie s'est installée
[Musique]
dans une dans une forêt donc en haut ce
qu'on a c'est quelques érables et
surtout les plus hauts le boulot à
papier qui est une espèce pionnière qui
s'installe en premier qui va pousser
rapidement ici les arbres sont plantés à
50 cm les uns des autres et on a testé
toutes sortes de combinaisons d'espèces
sur certaines parcelles on a aussi
planté des monocultures avec le recul
les chercheurs constatent que plus les
espèces sont différentes sur une même
parcelle plus celle-ci sont productives
on mélange deux espèces intolérantes à
l'ombre elles ont besoin de la même
ressource c'est-à-dire plein de lumière
en même temps ça fonctionne pas où elles
se font beaucoup de compétitions mais si
on mélange deux espèces dont l'une a
besoin de beaucoup de lumière va occuper
de l'espace et l'autre peut se contenter
de moins de lumière en sous-étage mais
ensemble elles vont pousser plus que la
moyenne de leur monoculture respective
c'est ça un effet de biodiversité donc
ensemble elles sont plus compétentes
pour exploiter les ressources au bout de
10 ans les chercheurs remarquent une
augmentation de 20% de biomasse sur les
parcelles plus diversifiées mais on est
loin de certains chiffres souvent
avancés lorsqu'il est question des
microforés comme par exemple quelle
pousserait 10 fois plus vite quand on
voit 10 fois plus rapide je pourrais pas
me prononcer sur la rapidité mais
probablement que ce jeune âge ils vont
pousser rapidement mais après ça le
chiffrer c'est difficile il faut
toujours comparer 10 fois plus
rapidement que quoi qu'un arbre qu'on
plante à habituellement en milieu urbain
ou qu'un arbre qu'on peut qui pousse
naturellement en forêt autre affirmation
souvent énoncée les microforés
séquestruraient 30 fois plus de carbone
c'est juste pas possible le chef est
juste trop gros et puis je trouve ça
malheureux qu'on met ça de l'avant alors
que en fait c'est pour d'autres raisons
qu'on devrait les mettre en place on
parle souvent de déficit naturel on
parle souvent d'enfants qui ont même pas
la chance d'aller à au cas par exemple
ou à Tremblant et la nature qui voit
c'est le parc avec quelques arbres
isolés et puis si on était capable de
recréer quelque chose comme dans lequel
on est ici ça sera déjà ça d'acquis pour
pour ses enfants là dans ces quartiers
là une microphorique coûte quelques
milliers de dollars car outre les
végétaux et la préparation du terrain il
faut entretenir les lieux pendant 3 ans
en désherbant et en arrosant mais c'est
peu pour tous les services qu'elle
rendront comme réduire les îlots de
chaleur ou purifier l'air c'est un
avantage aussi qu'il faut être mis à
profit par les municipalités de se dire
on a un espace vide plutôt que de passer
la tondeuse de mettre des engrais et
bien on va mettre une mini forêt comme
ça dans trois ans on occupe plus elle
coûte plus rien elle rapporte un arbre
c'est un investissement et non plus un
coup pour une municipalité c'est
vraiment un avantage
[Musique]
dans l'arrondissement de Rosemont
l'aventure des microphorets a débuté en
2021 un an plus tard la survie est bonne
très peu d'arbres n'ont pas passé
l'hiver petit clin d'oeil l'année
dernière on a mis des Lilas japonais ah
ouais et celui-là clin d'oeil a mis
japonais et au bout d'un an à peine on
voit déjà une nouvelle biodiversité qui
s'installe là où jadis il n'y avait que
du gazon